Pepi tuesday reject nation its ponytail
reaction time
everyone thinks john sexier than me so
i'm trying to be as much like john as
possible or my hair does not cooperate
when suddenly rains in California he
just gets twice as puffy and I can't
stand it now the humidity man all that
moisture in the air so now I am Mexican
John today this feels weird
this feels weird anyway screen jockeys
has released an honest trailer for one
of my favorite movies of last year
mother from director Darren Aronofsky
his soon-to-be wife Jennifer Lauren are
they getting married oh that's right
today I wanted to give a patron the day
shout out to none other than James stake
ins cuz he is like a mother to all of us
oh yeah he's very will give a full
shattered after the video I saw screen
junkies whole review on mother I did not
really care for this movie excited to
see them tear this apart and was one of
my favorite movies I love when they make
fun of them alright let's check it out
we asked you to vote for the 2017 movies
you wanted us to make it honest trailer
for here's your number for big you guys
are weird
[Music]
from the by beyond bertram for a dream
Black Swan and Bible allegory which is
kind of
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
show the baby you're the dumb one
perspective of meditation on the
creative process all critique of
traditional gender roles all a story
about how hard it is to date a famous
person in this film that refuses to
answer basic questions about plot or
characters but in those days when
Extreme Home Makeover would look like if
it were directed by Satan
[Music]
with this gruesome imagery that will
disturb you to your very core where a
baby be eaten alive is nothing compared
to a close-up of Javier Bardem smiling
Kristen getting acting serious and
unprepared public speaking we're just
racing see this is my actual worst
nightmare around and stares at the wall
but if that sounds boring when do you
hear when her husband is going through
he's a poet with writer's block
[Laughter]
oh right
[Music]
hated or releated in this field that
looks and sounds beautiful avoids easy
categorization and really makes the
audience think it's everyone
the whole thing will always go insane oh
yeah
I asked like question and she opened the
gates to hell but then a grub it's
somebody once told me that I was Mike
Wazowski I'm just a poor boy from a poor
family eating Thai paws doesn't make you
cool that was funny I was hilarious
Larry it's really funny I got a strong
feeling this one would be really funny
oh yeah I mean loved it or hated this
movie definitely lends itself to
something like this yeah it's easy to
make fun of - we did a non-spoiler
review and we did spoiler review on this
channel and I mentioned this in my top
ranking movies list that after a few
days I realized man I really love this
movie I just can't stop thinking about
it I'm like obsessed with the thought of
this movie is definitely distinct and it
definitely sticks with you and it's
definitely unlike a lot of things you've
seen ever it's fun to breakdown it's fun
to try to interpret it you know they're
talking about it's about this or it's
about that it's about it and I'm like
well it's kind of about all of that it's
just one giant themes and messages being
plastered in my face and some might find
that pretentious some might find that
annoying or something I find it
beautiful and captivating me I thought
it was thought-provoking so I really
enjoyed the hell out of watching the
movie and
love that it's freaking bad [ __ ] by the
end because here people say this movie
is crazy and you watch it for two hours
and you're like nothing's happened
that's that crazy and then you get to
the finale you're like this is some of
the craziest stuff I've seen in cinema
in a long time as a piece it is one of
the most sort of insane things I've seen
in years just in terms of how shrill and
jarring and claustrophobic and and nutty
it is as a movie and one of the things I
appreciate the most is that point that
you can kind of interpret it a bunch of
different ways and they're all valid
even though I feel like the Bible one is
the most the main one one point and I
gotta applaud a movie that has so many
kinds of a subtext
I could pull out of it because you know
that's arguably what the art of cinema
is for and I'm just surprised that this
got made at all I'm surprised they
didn't make fun of whatever she's doing
down in the cellar with the laundry and
the hole in the wall in the blood they
didn't make fun of that at all it's
pretty they make a joke about stuff
happens where the blood on the floor
that kind of stuff I don't actually know
what any of that means you know
everything else I know what god I see
what they're taught you not here it's
kind of hoping they make fun of that
stuff so that way I could be like maybe
they've interpreted a certain way so I
could try to understand a little better
I felt like it was like a decay and
infertility motif in some ways yeah
anytime there's like a festering hole
the woman has to you know kind of
confront and open up and deal with I
usually cook there's something to do
with that and especially like the
foreshadowing she's gonna have a baby
later bad things are gonna happen to
that baby later so I know a screen
junkies loves to make fun of movies
where a character stair hits stuff a
long lingering shots they would have a
really fun time with mostly pretty good
just did staring at a bunch of things
well anyway thank screen junkies for
doing that and hey hey shout out today
for James stake ins James Sagan's I know
that right now 2018 has not been the
most kind to you you've had some minor
setbacks I view them as minor even
though they're major in your life but
they're not my problem so they're just
minor to me that's how it worked that's
how I'd realize anyone else's problems
but James here's what I'll tell you
buddy the reason I want to give you a
shout-out today on this video
because you are exactly like a Darren
Aronofsky to me you seem to have this
deep cynical way of viewing life and you
know I think about it when you hang out
with James Dagon's he's got kind of a
twisted sense of humor and there's a
darkness about him and I'm right away
something heart-touching
about him as well this sweetie
underneath he's exactly he is darren
aronofsky meaning one day James you're
gonna bang a Jennifer Lawrence type
after he become really successful yeah
one of these days you're gonna grow a
mustache and have weak I'm sorry I'm
screwing his mustache you think about
scarves man scarves suits the snow and
he lives in the snow you got a scarf the
F up you are Darren Aronofsky and I am
Jennifer Lawrence oh hey that's gonna
make a beautiful year of your Ed Harris
anyway guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell and you can check out
our patreon become a patron oject today
it's like a second youtube channel you
have over 300 exclusive posts over there
so go check it out
love you guys ponytail out